So today we're going to be
talking about being a British
colonist,
which means we're going to be
discussing how you would feel if
you were part of the British
Empire in the mid-eighteenth
century,
living in the North American
colonies shortly before the
onset of the Revolution.
And for those of you who were
not here on Tuesday,
I talked for a little
while--I'll just mention it
here--
about how this course was
really going to be exploring the
mindset of the people who were
experiencing the Revolution to
really try to get at the logic
behind both what the British
colonists and the British
authorities were doing,
and how that ultimately
resulted in a war.
So we're really -- we're going
to try to really kind of create
two opposing forms of logic and
understand how they came to
oppose each other and how that
ended up leading in to conflict.
So it makes sense that as a
starting point we're going to
start by essentially talking
about some of the basics about
being a British colonist in
North America:
what their world would have
been like,
what your world would have been
like if you had been a colonist,
what your feelings would have
been about yourself as part of
the British Empire if you were a
colonist in the middle of the
eighteenth century.
Now I'll note here just in
passing that the first part of
Gordon Wood's Radicalism--
which I already mentioned
once--
that actually deals a lot with
a topic that I'll be talking
about today and I think in one
or two more lectures,
the sort of idea about what the
colonies were like prior to the
Revolution.
That book overall presents an
argument about how the colonies
went from monarchy--
The first third of the book is
monarchy and then the second
third of the book is
republicanism and then the third
is democracy,
and I think I said--Tuesday I
said,
"Think about what words
mean," and I'm sure that
will come into play in Gordon
Wood,
but the monarchy section not
surprisingly goes into some
depth about some of the things
I'm going to be talking about
today and on Tuesday,
which is, kind of:
life in the colonies before the
war,
sort of just basically what did
it mean,
how did it work,
how did society function.
Okay.
So let's actually start with
some of the basics.
The first and most basic:
If you were a British colonist
here in North America,
you would be living somewhere
along the Atlantic seaboard.
The colonial population was
largely clustered right along
the shoreline for really
practical reasons.
I'm sure you don't have to be
very imaginative to think why.
Obviously, for reasons of
trade, for reasons of shipping
and even just for reasons of
communication it made sense,
not to mention the fact that
people had a pretty healthy fear
of potentially unfriendly
Indians who were not
particularly pleased with the
idea of losing land to
potentially advancing settlers.
Now if you were male,
you might very well be a small
landholder because about sixty
percent of the white male
colonists owned land and,
as I'll talk about down the
road a little bit,
that's--actually when you
compare that with the rates of
land ownership in Europe,
that's actually pretty high,
it's a pretty high rate of
ownership,
and even in today's lecture
you'll see how that actually has
an impact on how things are
functioning in the American
colonies.
You probably would be a small
landholder.
You might be if you were living
in one of the small cities along
the coast maybe a merchant or an
artisan.
As a non-enslaved person,
you would probably have decent
clothes.
You'd probably have a decent
home.
You probably would have some
degree of economic and personal
independence,
and right around the
turn--let's say 1770--
you would be one of about two
million North American
colonists,
which is actually if you think
about it--
Certainly, if you--if I asked
you to guess how many colonists
there were in 1770,
you probably would not say two
million.
It's a lot.
And that includes both free
people and slaves,
and you would have been living
in a society that was so booming
with prosperity that between the
years 1700 and 1770--
so we're just talking about a
seventy-year period--
the population increased from
200,000 to over two million in
just a seventy-year period,
which is amazing.
So basically,
things were increasing.
Every decade the population was
increasing at a rate of roughly
thirty to forty percent.
That's a huge rate of growth.
You would be living in the
midst of a host of British
colonies,
so it's not just you along the
seaboard but obviously to the
north there is Canada,
to the south there were British
islands in the West Indies which
were known as the Sugar Islands,
and to the west was the vast
'scary wilderness' populated by
potentially unfriendly Indians
with what felt to you as though
it was an entirely foreign
culture,
and then of course to the
east--there is civilization to
your east.
There is the metropolis,
there is England,
there is culture in the minds
of the colonists and probably to
many people in England as well,
the height of cultural and
political sophistication.
When you looked to the east,
and it really was--
if you were a colonist it was
looking to the east towards
England that you really got a
sense of yourself as a British
colonist and really felt that
you belonged to something that
was powerful and admirable and
world-shaping and victorious.
Basically, you understood
yourself as being part of an
empire by identifying with that
center of empire to the east.
As an example of this,
just listen to someone who ends
up being a rather prominent
American revolutionary,
and I mentioned him as a matter
of fact on Tuesday.
I called him the doctor to the
stars and that's kind of unfair
to him, but Benjamin Rush.
He actually was a really
prominent man of science at the
time.
He moved in very high political
circles.
When I was thinking about this
lecture today I remembered,
or at least I hope I
remembered--I think I'm not
leading you astray--
I think that actually Rush
helped Thomas Paine edit
Common Sense,
and I think he edited out a
sentence that I wished Paine had
left in,
so I don't like Rush as an
editor very much.
I think I'll--we'll wait until
we get to Common Sense
but--
and supposedly,
allegedly, it's Rush who came
up with the title Common
Sense,
that Paine was going to
call it Plain Truth,
and Rush--I think Rush wins
on that.
I think Plain Truth is
not as snazzy as Common Sense
but either way--
So Rush -- The--My main point
here in blathering happily about
Rush is he's not some little
modest humbug of a guy.
Right?
He's someone of status.
So this is Rush's response when
he saw the throne of the King of
England.
So Rush said,
"I felt as though I were
on sacred ground.
I gazed for some time at the
throne with emotions that I
cannot describe."
Okay.
He's just dumbstruck at the
throne of the King of England,
just looking at it.
Now we sit here and we think
back.
We're: "Oh,
boy, aren't those monarchists
really cute,"
[laughs]
"those cute monarchists,
those silly people who are
amazed at a throne,"
which is pretty much I think
what I thought was--
wow, what an interesting phase
in American history when they
were dazzled by a throne.
Then, a couple of years ago I
ended up being lucky enough to
have a Member of Parliament show
me around the Houses of
Parliament.
And I was excited;
it was pretty neat and I'm
being all American
historian-ish,
you know: "Oh,
how similar,
how interesting when you
compare."
So I'm doing the geeky
historian thing and then this
member of Parliament who's
showing me around takes me in to
what he describes to me as the
robing chamber for the Queen
where she puts on her crown and
ceremonial robes before she goes
in to the House of Lords,
which I gather she does at the
beginning of every session of
Parliament.
Okay.
So I walk in to [laughs]
the robing chamber and at the
head of that room there's a
throne,
sort of an elevated throne,
so instantly,
without even thinking,
in my head, I'm thinking:
wow,
[laughs]
that's the throne,
and then I thought,
I just became Benjamin Rush.
Just like that,
I went right into the monarchy
vortex.
It didn't really take me very
long, so I can't chortle at Rush
anymore.
So there is something
impressive, and particularly at
this moment if you had been a
colonist--
and not that many people I
should say necessarily even got
to travel to Europe;
I'll talk a little bit about
that later on too--
but you certainly would have
been awestruck and impressed by
something like the throne of the
King of England.
Okay.
So, as suggested by Rush
quavering in front of the
throne, as a colonist you would
be proud to be British.
You would have a really deep
affection for the mother country
and it would be an affection
that was really rooted in bonds
of culture and tradition and
language.
Basically, you would really
consider yourself lucky to
belong to a powerful nation that
granted its citizens,
you believed,
more liberty than any nation on
earth.
Unlike other modern empires at
the time,
England seemed,
particularly to the English,
to be an empire that was bound
together not by force but by
bonds of interconnectedness and
affection as well as a joint
appreciation,
a real love,
of liberty and order.
And we're going to come back to
this idea of liberty a little
bit later in the course where we
start to really talk about the
logic of revolution,
but for now I'll just highlight
the fact that if you asked an
English-speaking person of the
eighteenth century about liberty
he or she would have told you
that liberty was worth more than
life.
Right? Liberty was it.
Liberty was what mattered.
It was the most important
possession of a civilized
people,
and of course the British
people, colonists and all,
felt that they were at the peak
of the civilized world.
As somebody at the time wrote,
"What signify riches?
What signifies health,
or life itself without liberty?
Life without liberty is the
most errant trifle,
the most insignificant
enjoyment in the world."
Okay, extreme,
but something to think about.
I suppose it's related to what
I said on Tuesday.
I think it's also easy to hear
some of this talk that sounds
really inflated and to dismiss
it as mere rhetoric,
and I'm sure there is some mere
rhetoric floating around here,
but it's important I think not
to dismiss things that sound
extreme and emotional as simply
emotional and extreme.
Some of this actually
represents sincere thought so I
think before you think these
guys are sort of overexcited
about things,
think to yourself that they
actually honestly may be
overexcited;
it might just be that they're
dramatic, but that they
sincerely feel these things.
There was a time when
historians did assume that a lot
of revolutionary rhetoric from
the colonists was actually kind
of inflated,
kind of for propaganda
purposes, and it took a while--
Actually, the Faces of
Revolution book by Bailyn,
part of the book that I
mentioned before that comes from
his larger book on the ideology
of the Revolution,
he's the guy who said,
"I've read several hundred
Revolutionary War pamphlets and
I actually think they're
serious.
I think we have to take them
seriously.
I don't think it's propaganda
or rhetoric.
I think they actually feel
these things."
So again, to us it might sound
a little inflated but their
feelings are really strong,
and again liberty is one of the
things that we'll find they're
feeling very strongly about.
So as a colonist,
you would be proud to be
British,
you would be really obviously
proud of British liberties,
and you would have been
particularly proud about being
British after the French and
Indian War in the 1760s,
when North American colonists
fought right alongside the
British army and helped them
defeat England's great enemy,
the French--and more on that to
come for sure,
but that was a really proud
moment for the colonists,
that they felt that they were
right there with the British
army fighting against the
French.
Above all else,
as British colonists you would
of course consider yourselves to
be British subjects through and
through,
equal to all other British
subjects,
even those living off in the
east in the metropolis.
You were a British subject and
you deserved the rights of a
British subject,
but as a colonist living on the
peripheries of the British
Empire,
on the edge of what was
perceived at the time to be a
howling wilderness,
which is one of those great
eighteenth-century ways of
referring to North America,
you also would be a little
nervous about your status as a
British subject,
worried about how you rated in
comparison with people living in
the mother country at the center
of the empire.
Everything seemed more
sophisticated in England,
and I suppose everything was
more sophisticated [laughs]
in England,
but it definitely seemed that
way to the colonists.
The clothes were more
fashionable;
the homes were grander and more
stately;
the intellectual life was rich
and challenging.
In comparison with the
sophisticated people in England,
you as a North American
colonist pretty much felt like a
country bumpkin;
you felt kind of dull,
kind of primitive,
somewhat rude,
and certainly you felt
potentially irrelevant.
You really did feel that you
were on the edge of a howling
wilderness.
So in essence,
like most British colonists in
North America,
if you were there at the time,
you would have had an ongoing
inferiority complex.
Now there were a number of ways
in which you might deal with
your insecurities.
One way to deal with that would
have been to become really
apologetic for what would have
been labeled as American speech
patterns or American manners,
and I've already given you one
arrogant British quote by that
fellow on Tuesday who said that
he was mortified that these
crude colonists spoke English
and could trace themselves to us
because they speak our language.
So that's sort of the ultimate
nasty stab at the colonists.
So you actually for good reason
might feel kind of embarrassed
about your manners and your
speech.
You probably would feel equally
embarrassed at the meanness of
your architecture,
your buildings--they're smaller
and less impressive--
at the pallor of your
intellectual life,
at the relative unimportance of
your public affairs.
Like a lot of colonial writers
who wrote pamphlets or books
addressed to an English
audience,
you probably would apologize
for the poor quality of your
work by reminding readers,
as one writer did,
"I live in the
uncultivated woods of America,
far from the fountains of
science and with but very rare
opportunities of conversing with
learned men."
That almost sounds like someone
who feels sorry for himself.
'I am so far from civilization.'
Or, you might boast about
colonial society,
not claiming to be better than
the mother country but instead
bragging that the colonies
represented Britain in
miniature;
that colonial legislatures in
this sense were kind of like
mini-Parliaments.
Or, you might admit that the
colonies were different from
England but boast that in the
same way that England once had
been pure and virtuous,
you in the colonies were
maintaining the sort of pure,
virtuous England,
and that England itself was
becoming corrupt and its cities
were becoming cesspools,
but there in the colonies you
were preserving the true British
heritage.
Still, whichever you chose to
rationalize or understand your
status as a colonist,
you could not escape the fact
that you were a colonist and
that you were far away from the
center of the civilized world.
As the young John Dickinson of
Pennsylvania put it,
and we're going to meet John
Dickinson again for sure later
on in the course,
he wrote to his father while he
was studying law in London and
he said that when colonists went
to England and saw "the
difference between themselves
and the polite part of the world
they must be miserable."
He actually thinks if
people--any colonist goes to
London and sees what the polite
part of the world lives like,
they'll never be able to hold
their head up in the colonies
ever again.
And Jefferson felt the same way.
Thomas Jefferson actually--as
much as he adored being
particularly in France,
he actually said more than once
that he thought that young
American men should not be
allowed to go to Europe because
if impressionable young men went
to Europe they would be so
impressed by Paris and London
that they would never be able to
hold their heads up in
Massachusetts or Virginia.
It would look so puny and
insignificant in comparison that
they would never be good
Americans ever again and that
they'd have to go back to
Europe.
Now of course the British
agreed generally with this
assessment of colonial society.
Colonists obviously were
inferior and rough and rustic
and crude,
so as promised,
here is yet another arrogant
British quote in my series of
arrogant British quotes.
In this case one British
observer noted,
"American colonists may
try to ape British habits and
customs but they're no more than
ruffled dunces."
I just think there's--these
guys have a real vim and vigor
for finding the little zippy,
stingy, nasty statement.
I think "ruffled
dunces" is a pretty good
one.
"What else could be
expected from aggrandized
upstarts in those infant
countries of America who never
have an opportunity to see,
or if they had,
the opportunity to observe the
different ranks of men in polite
nations?"
Notice how the colonies are
never polite.
[laughs]
There are the polite nations,
and then there's these scary,
howling wilderness colonists.
Along these same lines,
there's actually another
professor here at Yale,
Kariann Yokota,
and some of her work shows--
I found this really
fascinating--that the British
regularly sent damaged or
second-rate goods to the
colonists because they figured
the colonists wouldn't know the
difference.
They just kept the first-rate
stuff for themselves,
like: Broken?
Massachusetts.
[laughs] They'll never know.
Last week's, last year's style?
Massachusetts.
So basically all of this shows
that if Americans had an
inferiority complex,
they had some reason to have
one.
Now let me add at this point
that this anxiety about how the
colonists rated in comparison
with England,
specifically in Europe,
the polite world,
generally doesn't end with the
Revolution.
It's not as though suddenly we
win the Revolution and we don't
really care what the rest of the
world thinks.
Even after the colonies and
then the states had fought and
defeated the great power of the
British empire and successfully
created a new national
constitution,
Americans were still worried
about looking sophisticated
enough in the eyes of the world.
And my favorite example of
this--It's a little bit down the
road from the moment that we're
at in this course but I just
can't resist adding it in
because it's just--
it makes me happy and it's John
Adams--
and it's actually from 1789.
It's right when this new
national Constitution has gone
into effect and the Senate is
debating what the title should
be for the new national
executive.
Right?
We know there's going to be a
national executive.
We don't know what we're going
to call him.
And so the Senate is debating
this,
and someone in the Senate says,
"Well,
why don't we call him President
of the United States?"
Okay.
This horrifies John Adams,
absolutely horrifies him,
and as he says at the time--He
says,
"For God's sake,
there are presidents of cricket
clubs."
[laughs]
President of the United States:
and I'll quote him exactly
here.
He does say there are
presidents of cricket clubs but
he says in the Senate--
Where is it here?--"What
will the common people of
foreign countries,
what will the sailors and
soldiers say?
George Washington,
President of the United States?
They will despise him to all
eternity."
[laughter] Right?
So Adams is thinking in a world
where you have His Royal
Highness,
protector of the realm:
President of the United
States--
he's just thinking that there's
no comparison;
it doesn't rank.
So as we're going to be seeing
in future weeks of this course,
there's a constant thinking
about what--
how we are being looked upon
and that doesn't go away.
It shifts, it's different,
but it remains for quite some
time.
America in one way or another
always assumes they're being
watched and judged.
In the 1760s,
we'll see soon how these sort
of colonial feelings of
inferiority would help fuel the
hypersensitivity of the
colonists to infringements on
their rights by the mother
country.
Now despite all of this
anxiety, all of this inferiority
complex that I'm talking about
here,
as a colonist you did share a
base of assumptions and values
with your counterparts in
England.
So, first of all,
as an individual you assumed
that you lived in a great
hierarchy,
a sort of natural order,
everyone in his or her place,
deferent to those that were
beneath you,
respected but--I'm
sorry--deferent to those above
you--
That's a nifty order,
to be deferent to those beneath
you and respected.
You would be respectful to
those above,
and people below you would be
deferential to you,
so basically everyone is in
their place and everybody is
acting respectful and
deferential as they properly
should,
and this--you'll see a lot of
this in Gordon Wood.
Now of course the American
version of this great social
order,
this great hierarchy,
is different in some ways from
its British equivalent because
the colonies lacked both the
top-most and the bottom-most
rungs of society in England.
So in the colonies there wasn't
a titled entrenched aristocracy
and there wasn't an entrenched
peasant class.
Instead the colonies had what
some called a middling society
which was populated mostly by
either middling folk,
logically enough,
who had migrated from England
to better their lot in life,
by the English poor who hoped
to better themselves,
and by some of the lower ranks
of the English gentry like third
or fourth sons of the English
gentry,
who basically knew they weren't
going to inherit anything in
England and so their thought
was: well,
maybe if I head out to the
colonies I--
it'll be easier for me to get
some land there;
I'll be able to better myself;
I'll be able to basically make
something of myself there easier
than I can here.
Now if you were thinking about
going to the colonies and you
really wanted to get rich quick,
the West Indies was the place
to go,
though it also offered some of
the absolute worst living
conditions in the British
colonial world.
Life there was extremely hard.
There was unbearable heat.
All energies were focused on
gaining money and little else.
West Indian planters were so
focused on money,
money crops,
they actually didn't even
bother to grow their own food.
They imported food because they
didn't want to waste land,
energy, and resources on
growing their own food.
They were really focused on
their money crop.
If you went to the Indies to
get rich quick,
typically you either made it
big or failed miserably,
and either way typically what
happened is you would go to the
Indies,
you would establish a
plantation, you would find an
overseer,
you would put him in charge,
and then you would flee back to
England and be an absentee
landlord and let the people live
in misery in the West Indies
while you collected the profit
off of your sugar crop back home
in England.
Now the Indies,
not surprisingly,
might seem a little
intimidating.
If you wanted to get rich
quick, you might choose not to
go down to the scary sugar
islands.
You might decide instead to go
to the southern colonies to get
rich quick,
and for example it was largely
sons of the lesser gentry in
England who went to Jamestown at
the start of the seventeenth
century in Virginia.
And, logically enough,
since these are sons of the
lesser gentry and they consider
themselves to be above hard
labor,
they show up to this rather
primitive new colony in
Jamestown,
they refuse to work to grow
their own food,
and they starve to death.
[laughs]
That's a serious commitment to
your status.
'I'm sorry.
I'm above plowing.
I'm going to die now.'
[laughter]
You think sooner or later they
kind of figure:
a little plowing--life.
It's kind of--I don't know.
At any rate,
there's a reason why Jamestown
didn't do so well and there's--
a great example of this weird
mentality is Nathaniel Bacon,
who is a gentile colonist.
He's a younger son of a member
of the British gentry and in the
seventeenth century sure enough
he migrates,
he ends up in Virginia,
and he arrives in Virginia like
a lot of people assuming that he
deserved power,
he deserved land,
and he deserved status.
He's among the lesser gentry
but he still is among the upper
crust in England and now he's
arriving among the rude,
ruffled dunces [laughs]
of the colonies.
He assumes he's someone who
deserves what he wants.
Lo and behold,
he gets there and he finds that
actually in Virginia there's a
kind of an inner core of men,
self-made men,
who had been there for awhile,
or their families had been
there for awhile,
and basically they controlled
most of the land,
they controlled most of the
government offices,
they had most of the power,
and thus they could exclude
Bacon and others from getting
what they wanted.
Bacon obviously is a person
who's much more interested in
making money than in the good of
the colony so he responded to
his frustration at not being
able to get land or power by
surrounding himself with a pack
of equally-frustrated angry
young men who also wanted land
and also wanted power,
and eventually they came up
with the brilliant idea that
they would stage an enormous
attack on Indians,
massacre them all and steal
their land.
Brilliant plot.
So Bacon and his pack of guys
sort of go off and actually
start this in action.
The governor of the colony sees
that this is rapidly spinning
out of control and becoming
wild,
crazy Indian warfare so he
tries to stifle it and Nathaniel
Bacon and his friends did what I
suppose appeared logical to them
at the time.
They burned Jamestown to the
ground because they were angry.
[laughs]
Well, that's serious anger.
'Oh, you're going to stop us?
We'll just destroy the capital.'
[laughter] 'You're gone.'
Now the story is kind of
anticlimactic because Bacon
ultimately dies miserably of
dysentery while running away
from authorities so there's not
a lot of glory [laughs]
in Bacon's ultimate end,
but he's definitely a really
good example of greedy
self-interest and of the sense
of deservedness because of his
social rank and this disgust at
the power of these self-made men
in Virginia.
There were some gentry who
would have migrated to the
colonies who would have had some
kind of a similar feeling about
what they saw and what they
expected.
But the gentry was only a
minority of the people who
migrated to the colonies.
Most were lower in status,
some were of the lowest rank of
all, landless people and
sometimes criminals.
So if you committed a crime in
England,
you might be offered the option
between prison in England and
being sent to the colonies,
and to some this was actually a
really hard choice.
Right?
'Prison, the colonies,
prison, the colonies.
I don't know.'
The howling wilderness was very
scary.
Now some people opted for the
howling wilderness,
obviously, and some people,
poorer people,
decided to take their chances
on the colonies,
sold themselves into servitude
as indentured servants for five
to seven years at a time,
and in exchange their passage
was paid,
they owed a certain amount of
work,
and at the end of their time of
indenture they would get some
plot of land.
So there were a good number of
indentured servants,
and as a matter of fact some of
those Virginia power mongers who
were blocking Bacon out had
started out actually as
indentured servants.
That's--When you talk self-made
you're really talking self-made,
people who came,
did their indenture,
got some land and then really
built their way up.
So self-improvement obviously
is one reason to head to the
colonies.
Another reason,
another thing that might drive
you to head off to the colonies,
would have been if you belonged
to a religious minority that was
seemingly increasing unpopular
in England.
So if you were a Puritan,
if you were a Quaker,
if you were Catholic,
again probably middling in
status,
you might decide to try your
luck in the colonies where
either you thought there might
be more religious tolerance,
or just as likely there'd be
land so empty of people that it
wouldn't really be a worry of
yours.
There wouldn't be people around
there to be intolerant of you
and so it probably would be
better than what you were
experiencing in England.
Obviously, a lot of New England
was settled by Puritans with
that mindset.
Pennsylvania had the Quaker
faith at its cure--at its core.
It was founded by William Penn,
who was actually a member of
the aristocracy.
He became a Quaker and then he
used his high connections to get
a royal charter from the King to
found a colony for Quakers.
And Maryland began as a place
that was distinctly friendly to
people of the Catholic faith.
Now out of all of these kinds
of colonists that I'm talking
about here,
what was missing was a titled,
sort of to-the-manor-born,
established aristocracy of
dukes and duchesses unshakably
of the highest rank in society.
This doesn't mean that colonial
society didn't have an
established elite,
because certainly every colony
had certain great families that
controlled large amounts of
power and land.
And as a colonist,
and an average colonist,
you would have had no problem
differentiating these gentlefolk
from the common masses--
right?--these sort of gentlemen
and gentlewomen.
They dressed differently;
they held themselves
differently;
they spoke differently;
you addressed these people by
Mister or Madame or Esquire.
You actually visibly could tell
who the sort of upper-crust
people in society were.
Some families held obvious
power but again not in the
unquestionable way that the
aristocracy remained in control
in England.
A lot of these people that I
just mentioned had worked their
way into positions of
prominence,
so ultimately the line dividing
sort of upper-crusty people from
less upper-crusty people was
less sort of absolute.
It was less distinct than it
would have been in a country or
in a place where there was a
really established aristocracy.
So basically even though you
could tell who the elite are and
you could tell who the masses
are, there is slippage up and
down between the two.
It's not as though there is a
dividing line and you could
never hope to become an
aristocrat.
It's a little blurrier;
it's again a middling society;
it's part of what that means.
And because of that,
things like formal titles and
fine clothing were of extreme
importance in the colonies--
and in a lot of ways more
important in the colonies than
they were in England--
because they really were ways
of proving your status in a
place where you felt the need to
prove your status.
If you think about it,
your status would have been
just a matter of common
agreement.
You were only as lofty in
status as people believed you
were and if someone felt
compelled to call you by a title
or if you were wearing fine
clothing that people knew they
themselves couldn't afford,
that could go a long way
towards convincing people of
your status and importance.
So for example,
if you had any military service
at all,
even for the briefest moment
you'd served in the military,
and you were an officer,
you would insist forever after
to the end of your days that you
be called always by your title
like Colonel So-and-So or
Captain So-and-So.
That military title counted for
a lot.
That was really a sort of
unquestioned symbol of rank and
authority,
and in fact some people joined
the military just because they
knew by doing so they would get
a title and then they would be
able to hang on to that title to
really claim a place for
themselves in society.
And when I was researching my
first book I came across a case
where there were these two
guys--it sounds like a bad
joke--two guys in a tavern.
There were these two guys in a
tavern and one of them is a
military officer and one of them
isn't,
and I guess the guy who wasn't
a military officer wasn't so
clear on the whole rank thing
and he called the fellow by a
lower rank than he was:
well,
Captain Something instead of
Colonel Something--
and the guy was so insulted
that his title had been lowered
by who-the- hell-was-this-person
that he actually challenged him
to a duel right there.
'I'm sorry, but I'm willing to
kill you now.'
[laughs]
'You called me Captain.
You die.'
[laughter]
It was a serious insult,
a dread insult--and also he
might have just been a crazy
person but--
[laughs]
That's possible too,
but still it actually was a
serious insult.
And because military titles and
status went hand in hand,
sometimes strangers who seemed
to be high-ranking were just
called Colonel or General
because they seemed important
and thus they must have a
military rank.
And I actually found a diary of
someone, this sort of member of
the South Carolina elite,
and he was wandering around in
the backcountry.
And he says in his diary,
no matter where he went,
he was called Colonel,
which amazed him because he
said not only had he never had
any military service but --
and I don't know what this
means; I don't know enough about
him to know--
but he kept saying over and
over again,
'I really don't look like a
military person,
nothing about me,' so I'm
imagining this sort of sloppy,
scary guy who's wandering
around in the back country of
South Carolina and people are
saying,
'Colonel,' [laughs],--wow--and
people usually loved that.
This made him happy.
He wrote about it in his diary
because he liked it so much;
this made him a happy guy.
So obviously titles,
status, they're important and
they go hand in hand.
Now if you were in college in
the colonies--
so if you were at Yale,
if you were at Harvard,
if you were at King's College,
which is now Columbia--
these kinds of distinctions of
rank and status would have been
a part of your everyday life,
because when you entered
college you were listed as a
member of your class in the
order of your social rank.
Okay.
So the person of the highest
social rank is listed at the top
of the class and the person of
the lowest social rank is listed
at the bottom of the class,
and at commencement ceremonies
or graduation ceremonies the
highest in rank was the one who
got to speak the longest and
give the longest public
address--
and obviously because,
as I've been saying,
things are less entrenched,
what this meant was lots of
really petty,
nasty squabbling at a lot of
universities because everybody
had a complaint.
'Well, I'm not on the bottom.
Well, I certainly have a better
rank than him.
He should be at the
bottom.
I should be at the--'
So certainly it's a contentious
issue at colleges,
and what this meant,
oddly enough,
is that when the grading
system--
when people actually figured
out that you could have a
grading system and base--
judge people based on grades,
then unbelievably this was seen
as a great relief.
This made people really--Grades
made people really,
really happy,
because it meant that you could
be judged based on merit and not
based on rank or social class.
So you can give thanks to the
democracy of grades.
Remember that during this
semester.
I'll remind you.
Give thanks for your grades.
Okay.
So we've talked about some of
the similarities and differences
in social rank between colonists
and people living in England.
I want to just take a few
minutes to talk about some
assumptions about government and
about rights,
about individual rights,
because one of the periods of
great migration to the colonies,
which was the
mid-to-late-seventeenth century,
was also a period in which
Parliament asserted its
dominance in England.
So while all Englishmen
believed in the importance of
political liberty and
legislative representation and
the rule of law and all of these
things I've started to talk
about,
the colonies were full of
people who either themselves had
left England or were descended
from people who had left England
when that kind of belief was at
an all-time high,
so colonial governments
embodied that spirit to a really
extreme degree.
And it's important to realize
that colonial talk of liberty
wasn't some kind of colonial
innovation.
It was the most heartfelt of
British traditions --
as I've suggested just in this
lecture,
and as we're going to see in
future weeks--
it's the precise meaning of
liberty as translated into the
colonies from England--
and as this slowly shifts over
time,
it's going to help raise
conflict between the colonies
and the mother country.
But questions about the precise
meaning of liberty wouldn't
really become an issue until the
1760s,
after the French and Indian War
when,
as we'll soon see,
the British would end what had
been a long period of what's
often called a period of
salutary neglect,
a period when the British
largely just left the colonies
alone to regulate themselves.
And throughout that period of
neglect colonists had lived
immersed in their sense of
English rights and privileges,
unaware of the ways in which
the colonial experience--
just the experience of living
in the colonies--
had suddenly altered their
understanding of these rights.
They've been able to live in
that kind of a freedom largely
because of the nature of the
British imperial administration.
Typically, rather than exerting
great control over the
colonization process the British
Crown tended to leave
colonization largely to private
enterprise,
so like a joint-stock company
would get a grant to establish a
colony,
and off they'd go,
and it wasn't really
necessarily the Crown that had
its hand on everything.
It was these private companies
that were often taking care of
the colonization efforts,
and on a few occasions when the
Crown did pass trade regulations
they didn't enforce them very
rigorously,
which basically allowed
widespread smuggling and
bribery.
So in a sense,
the success of the British
imperial system up until the
1760s was largely due to what
was not really a policy,
but the absence of a
policy--right?--
this neglect of the colonies by
the mother country.
Not until the British began to
actively regulate the colonies
in the mid-eighteenth century
did it really become apparent
that colonial and British ideas
about the role of the colonies
and the rights of colonists had
really begun to drift apart.
Had the colonists forfeited
some of their English liberties
by migrating to the New World or
not?
Were they dependent on the
mother country or were they just
contributors to the greater
empire?
And some colonists would come
to have a clear answer to those
kinds of questions.
They would argue--and we're
going to see this in weeks to
come,
and specifically people writing
this argument and offering it to
the public--
that the original settlers of
the colonies had been free-born
subjects of England who had left
England with the authorization
of the monarchy and,
taking a good many personal
risks, had created thriving
English settlements at little
cost to the English government,
bringing England great riches
in the process.
So essentially some colonists
would argue not only were they
English, but they made personal
sacrifices for England;
they had tamed a wilderness for
England, for the sake of the
empire.
And ironically it would be that
mentality--
that kind of outcry for the
rights of Englishmen--
that would help lead the
colonists to revolt against
England.
As we'll see,
in a sense, the colonies were
never as English as when they
rebelled against the mother
country for the rights of
Englishmen.
And I will stop there.
On Tuesday we will be looking
at some things that were
distinctly American about the
colonial experience.
Have a good weekend.